I think there's an obnoxious amount of  talented 15 to 20 year olds that are  completely unknown and I think what I  would do and what I've told some like  companies I buys for or people looking  you gotta look at places that dribble  and forests are an amazing you know  place to look for people like that  you've got to figure out where they're  hanging out like there's always a new  place where they're hanging out and most  of all similar to what I said earlier  you can't go I'm and like just start  selling right if you're not willing to  make the investment to be part of the  community you're never going to win that  game without paying the highest price